[Music]
on this Sunday night it was not to be
Canada's crushing defeats and history
making goals it was the first best five
minutes of Canadian football history
what went wrong and what's next
Canada's ambitious indo-pacific
blueprint to counter China's economic
aggression on the international stage
plus the after dinner damage control for
Donald Trump
why did the former president a rapper
and a white nationalist whine and dine
together
and a new approach to dementia care it
is an absolute godsend absolutely the
European treatment model shaping
Ontario's strategy
global national with para Nasser
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin tonight in Qatar where
Canada's World Cup hopes have been
dashed after a heartbreaking defeat by
Croatia but history was also made today
by the Canadian men's soccer team
scoring our country's first ever goal at
the world's biggest soccer tournament
even if it wasn't enough
Soccer Star Alfonso Davies born to
Liberian parents at a refugee camp
before resettling in Canada did
something the 1986 team couldn't scored
a goal 67 seconds into the game sadly
our fortunes ended there Croatia went on
to wipe Canada 4-1 gutting our hopes of
advancing to the next stage but for
Canadian fans in Qatar and back home the
game was worth every second
it was the first best five minutes of
Canadian football history scoring
Davey's two minutes in it was amazing
happy we made it here but uh was hoping
to get at least get one win I was so
happy to be here today for the two
minutes because it just felt like
everybody was wanting the same thing and
so being able to watch Alfonso Davies
just head that thing right into the
corner of that net was unbelievable
seeing them play so well it's just
really nice to finally see Canada on the
big stage oh it's exhilarating they
finally scored a goal first time in
about like 30 years so that was
fantastic and Davey's the Wonder Boy did
it
joining me now from just outside the
stadium in Qatar is Joshua cloak a
writer for the athletic who's been
closely following the Canadian men's
team's entire world cup Journey he
recently released a book about all of it
just before the tournament called the
voyagers Josh it's great to have you
with us I mean first of all I have to
ask you I mean that historic goal from
Alfonso Davies off the top of the game
what was it like to be in there and what
was it like to be in there for the whole
game
well yeah there is a moment
um just before Alfonso Davies gets his
head on that incredible cross from Tejon
Buchanan where you know the stadium does
just go silent a little bit perhaps
because they know what's coming uh look
it was incredible it was an incredible
display of all the talent that Alfonso
Davies had and you could just kind of
feel this release from the Canadian team
that finally they got over that first
hump you know one of their stated goals
was to score a goal at the World Cup
um and now that they have it it's just
such an iconic moment too
um and something that I hope you know
Canadians talk about for a long time
yeah I mean I think the the cheers were
heard from here to Qatar but we know now
that Canada started crumbling just after
that that moment of Glory what do you
think went wrong for their performance
they ran up against a very very smart
Croatian team Croatia's Midfield three
um is about as smart a Midfield three as
you'll find in International Football
Today once that Midfield three kind of
figured out the timing of Canada's
presses
um the moments when Canada would press
they realized where Canada would be
vulnerable so I think once you run up
against a team that has those kind of
smarts and that has more importantly
than that the experience right that's
what Canada doesn't have once Croatia
figured out their press it was it was
game over
you know Canada doesn't have the
experience yet so that leads me to my
next question what do you think is next
for this team and for Canadian men's
soccer Beyond this tournament
look Canada leaving here with a result
is something that they can be proud of
but I think they have to look at this um
tournament as a whole and really study
the way other teams and other
organizations especially operate and I
think being around these world-class
organizations like Croatia it's an
opportunity to study from them so I hope
um just as someone who wants to see the
Game grow that Canada will have studied
you know all the organizations they can
hear and can take those learnings and
apply them to 2026.
you know you've you've written a book
about this as I mentioned you're you're
so intertwined into What's Happening
Here one of many journalists there who
are covering it I know in my house with
my husband and my son it was just such
sadness what is the mood like among the
Canadians there and with you
well I mean my mood is is secondary uh
you know you could definitely feel the
Canadian fans in attendance deflated
um and I say that because you know they
showed up so so well for the game
against Belgium um so I think for a lot
of Canadians that there's probably a lot
of sadness with the realization that
they're still so far to go to be that
that top top Soccer Nation
um but you you have to believe as well
that they're going to show up well for
for Morocco because you know when that
support was at its best I think that's
when Canada was playing well too right
so so they need that support as well
Joshua cloak thanks so much for your
coverage
there is a Canadian championship to
celebrate at the World Cup of tennis a
little later on in the newscast Eric
Sorensen is going to look at Team
Canada's tennis stars the ones Turning
Heads this year at the Davis Cup
turning to trade relations now the
federal government unveiled its
long-awaited indo-pacific strategy today
to move away from over-reliance on China
and tap into one of the world's fastest
growing economies by 2040 the
indo-pacific region is expected to make
up half of the world's economic activity
and as David Aiken reports the new
strategy seeks to protect national
interests without compromising Canadian
values and principles
there's a generational Global shift
happening many in Canada agree and have
been calling for years for a reset of
Canada's approach to the indo-pacific
I'm certainly this is a good thing it's
a long overdue yes but what I've seen in
there is content rich and it's backed up
by dollars so the intentions are are
pure I think what matters nowadays David
is we're able to convert actions uh
sorry those intentions into actions and
those actions into actual achievements
the growing economic importance of
Asia's Pacific countries is one thing
but this new indo-pacific strategy is
mostly motivated by China's rise as a
global actor and its advancement of
unilateral claims foreign interference
and increasingly coercive treatment of
other countries
so Canada will deploy more Naval forces
and other military Assets in the Pacific
we will challenge China when we need to
and we will cooperate with China when we
must Canada will also beef up its cyber
security infrastructure and may restrict
some Chinese investment in Canada we
must be vigilant against the very real
and serious threats of foreign
interference cyber attacks hostile
activities ideological extremism
disinformation and international crime
Networks
the government believes one of the best
ways to deal with the rise of an
aggressive China is to strengthen
relations with its friends in the
regions especially India and as India
the world's largest democracy becomes
the most populous country in the world
its strategic importance and Leadership
will only increase Canada will seek to
begin trade talks with India that might
lead to the kind of free trade deals
Canada has with the likes of Japan and
Korea Canada will boost academic and
cultural exchanges and Canada promises
to beef up Visa processing capacity in
India specifically in New Delhi and
Chandigarh we've got to address that
because it is uh it's it's a it's a
black mark on you globally if you can't
help get the people in that you're
trying to recruit into your country
and to do all this the government is
prepared to spend just over two billion
dollars over the next five years David
Akin Global News
Ottawa
record-setting inflation is taking its
toll on another commodity Parcels being
mailed out for the holidays sending a
package through Canada Post or through
Courier Services is going to cost you
extra something many Canadians are
already discovering Ross Lord reports
for the Bates family in Nova Scotia this
is precious cargo it's Christmas
presents for grandchildren and and uh
and their parents the weight of the
parcel is compounded by a fuel surcharge
of almost 40 percent to have Canada Post
ship it overseas I'm going to say that
to ship that box to where it's going
we'll probably be in the 125 dollar
range the Canadian taxpayers Federation
suggests the crown Corporation is going
too far with 40 percent uh 40 being
added we're going to see tens of
millions of dollars in increased profit
for Canada Post Canada Post says a fuel
surcharge has been standard practice for
nearly 20 years and simply reflects
market dynamics like the price of diesel
that's risen to more than two dollars
per liter for customers it makes holiday
Parcels yet another hit in a year full
of cost increases it has gone up I have
noticed I just did it for the first time
in a few months months now and it was
about twelve fifteen dollars more Canada
Post is not alone and adding a fuel
surcharge on Parcels at Purolator which
is ninety percent owned by Canada Post a
package weighing two kilograms sent from
Halifax to Toronto costs fifty dollars
plus another eighteen dollars in fuel
surcharge after taxes that's 82.78 the
fuel amount thirty five percent of the
base price pure later says its surcharge
is set monthly based on a four week
average diesel price some customers are
looking for ways to avoid the extra
costs and found out the prepaid boxes
are the best way to go
they don't have a fuel surcharge and you
can put a certain amount in for a
certain amount of money up to 34 dollars
anywhere in Canada another escalating
price that's taxing the creativity of
Canadians
Ross lore Global News Halifax
and Trump does damage troll coming up
the former presidents
dinner guest
blaming rapper rap Kanye West
it's been less than two weeks since
Donald Trump announced he was running in
2024 but already the former president's
team is in damage control mode and it's
all over a dinner a holocaust denying
white supremacist dinner guest to be
exact at his Mar-A-Lago estate also
their controversial rapper Kanye West
who says he's also running for president
Jennifer Johnson reports on what this
early Scandal could mean for Trump's
presidential ambitions
he's still the biggest draw in the
Republican party but former president
Donald Trump is in hot water again last
Tuesday Trump hosted a dinner at his
Mar-A-Lago home with music mogul Kanye
West who has been denounced for his
anti-Semitism Wes brought along Nick
Fuentes a politically active white
supremacist and Holocaust denier we've
got the white Christian men that built
this country the first time and we'll do
it again word that Fuentes was at the
dinner quickly spread just as quickly
Trump took to his social media platform
claiming the dinner was West's idea and
he didn't know Fuentes but West posted a
video with a different take Trump is
really impressed with Nick Fuentes the
president has long bragged about his
close relationship with Jewish Americans
although he received only 30 percent of
the Jewish vote in the 2020 election
just over a week ago Trump made it clear
he is counting on their support in 2024.
and soon with the help of the Republican
Jewish Coalition and Patriots all across
this land we will be a great nation
again but Jewish friends of Trumps and
many republican leaders are now
questioning his lack of judgment it's
very troubling and it shouldn't happen
and we need to avoid those kinds of
empowering the extremes on vacation in
Nantucket President Joe Biden was asked
to comment
but only said you don't want to hear
what I think while the White House
officially condemned the dinner this
latest controversy comes As Trump
continues to battle the Department of
Justice over its investigation of
classified documents the former
president brought to his Florida home I
would expect that we are going to see
something either at the very end of this
year or the beginning of next year with
regard to a potential indictment in this
matter as a candidate for president
Trump has no legal protection against
any indictment nor are many Jewish
Americans for getting his relationship
with Kanye West who in a bizarre twist
announced last week he asked Trump to be
his running mate in the 2024
presidential race
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
anger over China's strict zero coveted
strategy is reaching a boiling point as
unprecedented protests unfold in major
Chinese cities
[Applause]
a large group of protesters yelling down
with Xi Jinping in Shanghai demanding an
end to lockdowns some dragged out and
arrested by police there have also been
similar scenes of disobedience in
Beijing and Nanjing a rare wave of
public anger comes after an apartment
fire in northwest China this past
Thursday killed 10 people many speculate
coveted lockdown measures made it
tougher for residents to escape the
flames
rescue crews on the southern Italian
resort island of iskia off the coast of
Naples are combing through thick mud and
debris tonight after Saturday's deadly
landslide
[Applause]
at least seven people are known to have
died and another 12 people are still
missing the sheer force of the slide
swept away cars and buses parts of the
island were buried in six to seven
meters of mud after 126 millimeters of
rain fell in just six hours the Island's
heaviest rainfall in some 20 years
[Music]
I had learning lessons from Europe a new
approach to dementia care now in Ontario
with a long waiting list
[Music]
dementia is on the rise in Canada to the
point where one in five Canadians will
experience caring for someone living
with Alzheimer's or Parkinson's or any
other of the neurological diseases under
the dementia umbrella anybody who has a
parent with dementia knows just how hard
it is and also how few resources are out
there to help them out as Mike troulet
reports Ontario is now borrowing a page
from a European treatment model and it's
already in high demand
The Tipping Point for Joni Shiner came
about five years ago that's when her now
83 year old husband Murray's Alzheimer's
took a turn he began to wander forget
his pills and as time passed his ability
to navigate everyday life declined when
this picture was taken Joni says her
husband didn't know he was holding their
grandson there are still good moments
just not as many as there used to be
otherwise he sits in his chair and he
goes like this and he sleeps all day he
falls asleep in front of the TV he maybe
will get up for lunch maybe 61 percent
of Canadians with dementia still live at
home but so many of them struggle one in
four suffer from depression another 28
percent require extensive assistance
which caregivers like Joni say fall
short of what is needed so the province
of Ontario is trying something new
this Center in Toronto's North End will
soon be the second in the region to
offer Adult Day programs keeping Murray
active and giving Joni a break it is an
absolute godsend absolutely Circle of
Care CEO Carrie lucky has been trying to
get the Center built since 2016. when
her mother Margaret was living in a
long-term care home it was the vision
why I wanted this because I didn't have
this for my mother the model of care in
the province she reasoned was outdated
with the number of dementia cases
outpacing the ability to care for them
we have no choice but to change
absolutely we have to we have to look at
different models so they look to
countries like Denmark and France where
an approach to keep patients more
engaged in life has led to increased
behavioral and cognitive scores which in
turn delays the need for long-term care
they love this instead of sitting in
front of a TV they play games anything
to keep their minds active we we look at
what they're able to do and what not
what they're not able to do and that's
the Cornerstone of our practice engaging
them this Center won't be open until the
first week of December yet they already
have a waiting list the demand is so
great Public Health has already told
them they can increase capacity they
need more more and more and more I am so
excited
they need they need more they need more
you can vent other provinces will be
taking note as more Canadians seek
support for living with dementia
microlyte Global News Toronto
the BC government says it's pulling out
all the stops to try to recruit more
doctors to the province you can't
privatize our way to a Better Health
Care System that's why we're taking
action to get more internationally
trained doctors off the sidelines
the province's new plan will triple the
number of spaces available for foreign
trained doctors and will expedite the
process of accreditation before
Physicians arrive in Canada more than a
million British Columbians are without a
family doctor
an update now to a story we brought you
yesterday Winnipeg Police have arrested
a man after a random kidnapping in the
Portage la Prairie area on Friday
Michael Steven klimchuk was arrested and
charged on Sunday morning he was wanted
in connection to the kidnapping of a 25
year old woman and her two-year-old's
daughter
and that is global national for this
Sunday night I'm Farah Nasser and on
behalf of our whole team here at global
national I want to thank you so much for
spending part of your evening with us
tonight's your Canada is the North
Saskatchewan River with a view of
Edmonton we love senior Canada so please
keep emailing us those photos to viewers
at globalnational.com Donna we'll be
back with you tomorrow until next time
take care of yourselves and each other
good night
foreign